[Musica]
come potete vedere oggi su questo palco
non sono da sola o come una matrioska
tutti noi sappiamo come sia una
matrioska non ha bisogno di
presentazioni è un oggetto che si apre
con un pezzo chiamato madre e si chiude
con un pezzo chiamato assieme ed ha un
significato ben preciso è simbolo di
generosità e famiglia ma oggi qui con
voi proverò a dare un significato
diverso alla matrioska un po di tempo fa
sono stata contattata per partecipare a
questo evento
sapevo cosa fosse un ted e pensavo di
dover parlare di tematiche
economico sanitarie di riorganizzazione
dei processi ospedalieri tematiche
affini al mio mondo lavorativo ma poi
quando stampa l'abstract mi resi conto
che non era proprio come avevo
immaginato
mi soffermai sul titolo scritto in
grassetto e lessi ombre
e poi continua e
sovrastrutture schemi rotture degli
schemi
ma io non sono un'esperta di tematiche
sociali
ma poi fa sì che in realtà queste
tematiche non sono così lontane da me e
da nessuno di voi qui presenti
fin dalla nascita o addirittura prima
siamo spinti a creare degli schemi che
ci permettano di vivere
pensate al mondo animale a come le api
costruiscono gli alveari oa come le
formiche trasportano il cibo oppure
anche a come gli indigeni dell'africa
creino delle coreografie danzanti per
darti il benvenuto all'interno della
loro tribù è sì quella sono proprio io
durante il mio viaggio in kenya e ora a
pensandoci bene ho capito che quello era
il loro modo di salutare quel modo che a
me sembra strano e bizzarro come per
loro però potrebbe essere strano
il nostro modo la nostra mente funziona
infatti per schemi molto limitati
oggi sono qui sul palco per parlare di
un argomento ben preciso le ombre o 18
minuti non posso leggere le slide e non
posso fare pubblicità ma pensa te
insieme a me ma vi sembra anche a voi
che i primi a darmi degli schemi sono
stati proprio gli editor di ted
loro sono stati bravi parlano di dieci
comandamenti
ma in realtà non hanno fatto altro che
delineare uno schema che oggi mi
permette di essere qui sul palco insieme
a voi a raccontarvi qualcosa di
interessante
o almeno lo spero
il nostro cervello
funziona per schemi proprio con un pc
che dopo essere stato formattato una
volta imparata la risposta crea degli
automatismi che ci permettano di
risparmiare energia
come quando guidate un'automobile o come
quando andate a sciare o andare in
bicicletta una volta imparato
quell'automatismo non lo dimenticherete
più
ma se la formattazione di quel pc fosse
andato male
o se la registrazione di quelle
abitudini avesse dei byas
l'autopilota è funzionale solo quando
non trasforma lo schema in una gabbia
quella che vedete qui è la storia di sei
serie che non avevano mai incontrato un
elefante prima la prima volta incontrano
l'elefante ognuno di loro tocca la parte
diversa del corpo e c'è chi tocca la
coda e si immagina essa una corta c'è
chi tocca la proboscide e si immagina
sia un serpente ognuno di loro da uno
schema diversa alla levante e ovviamente
questo schema è difforme dalla realtà
proprio perché loro hanno un'esperienza
limitata
la morale è che gli schemi influenzano
la nostra vita quotidiana e delle volte
diventano e dei limiti che ci tengano
ancorati a delle abitudini sbagliate
ragionate commenti se da una parte lo
schema è fondamentale perché come un
navigatore ci guida nelle strade della
nostra vita dall'altra dall'altra parte
dobbiamo essere bravi noi a capire
quando questo navigatore ha smesso di
funzionare per evitare possibili errori
a chi di voi non è mai capitato di avere
un parente ricoverata al pronto soccorso
in attesa di un posto letto
è un po come il gioco della sedia ma
quando si stoppa la musica dovremo
recuperare il letto
avete mai pensato il perché questo
accada
la risposta a questa domanda non è
semplice ma oggi proviamo a trovarla
insieme
quella che vedete le mie spalle è la
storia di marco e acceda al pronto
soccorso per broncopolmonite
raccontata attraverso la mappatura del
suo processo come una fotografia che ci
permette di capire quali sono gli schemi
organizzativi
e quali sono le inefficienze ovvero quei
triangolini rossi che vedere lì
rappresentati in questa storia il
principe la principale criticità è il
fatto che marco aspetti un posto letto
per molto tempo al pronto soccorso
questo triangolino è un campanello
d'allarme perché ci deve far capire che
gli schemi che finora erano stati
utilizzati in quella organizzazione non
stanno funzionando più come dovevano
funzionare
e quindi cosa abbiamo deciso di fare
abbiamo deciso di prendere questo
problema e trasformarlo in un
opportunità
implementando una soluzione che oggi qui
con voi vorrei chiamare lavagna in
realtà si chiama fiano per ogni paziente
e in questa lavagna vengono
rappresentati i pazienti i giorni della
settimana
le attività programmate le attività
erogate
questa lavagna non solo ha rotto quegli
schemi che determinavano l'inefficienza
ma è andata a
creare un nuovo schema organizzativo
che permette all'azienda di essere più
efficiente
ora l'infermiera 72 ore prima della
dimissione rimuovere promuove il
catetere al paziente e il giorno prima
il medico prepara la lettera di
dimissione mentre lost programma al
trasporto in ambulanza
ecco questo nuovo schema ha fatto sì che
quel posto letto si liberasse proprio
nel momento in cui marco ne aveva
bisogno senza farlo aspettare al pronto
soccorso
quindi se vogliamo far emergere gli
schemi errati le abitudini sbagliate
dobbiamo prima cosa
mappare e capire la situazione dove
siamo
seconda cosa capire quali sono le
inefficienze e far sì che queste
inefficienze diventino opportunità di
miglioramento
implementando delle soluzioni questi tre
passi ci permettano di capire dove siamo
e dove vogliamo arrivare
le strade per passare da b sono molte
una volta trovata la strada migliore la
cosa più difficile sarà rendere
operativa la soluzione avete pensato
perché sarà quella soluzione che andrà a
impattare e sull'organizzazione
dell'azienda
per fare questo non servono degli eroi
serve soltanto sviluppare la cultura del
cambiamento
in un azienda ospedaliera la cultura del
cambiamento è difficile da implementare
perché molte volte incontra una
resistenza e incontra la resistenza
della cultura si è sempre fatto così
quella cultura organizzativa che è molto
conservativa e che
fa sì che professionisti non pensino che
ci sia bisogno di cambiare
e che i professionisti credono di essere
infallibili quando succede un errore non
vanno a chiedersi il perché è su ciò
perché è successo quell'errore ma
tendono a giustificarsi una cultura che
punta al cambiamento continuo è quella
dell'aviazione invece in questo settore
così
pericoloso nel corso degli anni si è
assistito a un aumento della mortalità
vi siete mai chiesto il perché queste h
questa accaduto perché quando succede un
incidente
è prassi andare a recuperare la
cosiddetta scatola nera che ti permette
di capire quali sono i problemi che
hanno causato quell'evento per fare per
far sì che quelle azioni non si ripetano
mai più
per cui se un tempo i nostri nonni
preferivano spostarsi in treno noi oggi
di gran lunga preferiamo spostarsi in
aereo e questa logica organizzativa ha
preso parte nella sanità in uno dei
momenti più complessi proprio quando
è apparsa la pandemia
quindi in un momento in cui la pandemia
è stato come ferite che ha rotto tutti
gli schemi organizzativi
questa logica ha portato dei risultati
straordinari
non c'era più il medico di chirurgia non
c'era più il l'infermiere dell'urologia
i professionisti erano lì tutti insieme
e erano riconoscibili soltanto dal nome
scritto dietro e la loro casacca di
protezione
sembrava di essere in una miscela
spaziale ma l'obiettivo non era
raggiungere la luna bensì curare il
paziente ecco che anche in questo caso
abbiamo assistito alla diffusione della
cultura del cambiamento all'interno di
un'organizzazione aziendale come quella
sanitaria
per concludere avevo promesso e
che vi avrei raccontato di dare una
nuova immagine alla matrioska io vorrei
immaginare che i nostri schemi
organizzativi e i nostri schemi di vita
siano rappresentati da queste matrioske
che le loro pareti legnose rappresentino
i nostri confini politici sociali
religiosi e che i loro spazi
circoscritti rappresentino le nostre
abitudini
tutti noi fin da piccoli siamo stati
abituati a vivere dentro nella matrioska
cucita su misura dai nostri genitori ma
poi a un certo punto siamo stati noi a
decidere in quale matrioska entrare cioè
che la scelta per il colore c'è chi l'ha
scelta per la forma e che per la
grandezza
c'è chi si è trovato bene nella
matrioska ed è rimasto
e poi c'è chi si è trovato male ed ha
pensato di cambiare ma sono sicura che
c'è anche chi comunque soddisfatto della
matrioska in cui viveva ha deciso di
cambiare ma cosa hanno in comune tutte
queste persone la necessità di vivere
all'interno di schemi impostati da loro
o dall'organizzazione
quindi
siate voi a decidere se rimanere in
quella matrioska oppure uscire
ma ricordatevi che una volta usciti
dalla matrioska sarete sempre
all'interno di un'altra matrioska i cui
confini dipenderanno solo da voi
d'ora in avanti quando vedrete una
matrioska spero che la osserverete con
occhi diversi grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]